Stephen King se veut rassurant : le vocabulaire,
c’est comme le pénis.
Comme le disait la pute au matelot intimidé
: L'important, c'est pas ce que tu as, mon
chou, mais comment tu t'en sers.
Je ne suis pas un grand fan de Stephen King
; je n’ai probablement lu qu’un ou deux
de ses livres à l’adolescence, et je ne
me souviens même plus lesquels.
Mais on m’a chaudement recommandé ce livre
: Écriture, mémoires d’un métier, dans
lequel le célèbre maître du thriller réfléchit
au sens profond de la création littéraire
et donne des recettes au lecteur pour qu’il
puisse s’y mettre lui aussi.
J’en ai tiré 10 règles grâce auxquelles
vous pourrez écrire comme Stephen King.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Stephen King a commencé à écrire et à
soumettre des textes à des éditeurs très
tôt - dès l’enfance, en fait.
Bien évidemment, il a d’abord reçu beaucoup
de refus avant de finalement percer.
Il empalait les lettres de refus sur un clou
dans sa chambre, et assez rapidement, comme
il continuait d’écrire, il a eu besoin
de clous plus longs.
Mais il a persévéré ; il a beaucoup travaillé
pour progresser.
En particulier, il était très régulier.
Il faut écrire chaque jour.
Lui, Stephen King, se donne pour objectif
10 pages quotidiennes - c’est-à-dire environ
2000 mots - même si c’est devenu de plus
en plus difficile depuis qu’il a arrêté
de fumer, et aussi parce qu’il prend de
l’âge.
Il est tellement régulier qu’il ne fait
strictement aucune exception.
Dans les interviews, il se fait un peu passer
pour l’Américain moyen, qui ne travaille
ni le week-end, ni les jours fériés, et
qui prend des vacances - mais il ment, un
peu comme le bon élève qui n’assume pas
sa rigueur de travail et qui la fait passer
pour du talent.
Au débutant, Stephen King conseille d’essayer
d’écrire 1000 mots par jour, et éventuellement
de prendre un jour de repos par semaine.
Et pour être aussi régulier, il faut travailler
dans certaines conditions.
C’est une règle très connue ; on nous
l’a répétée depuis l’enfance, notamment
à l’école ; et aujourd’hui le milieu
des startups, et plus globalement des entrepreneurs,
fantasme dessus - ils appellent ça le focus.
Cette règle, c’est tout simplement qu'il
faut miser sur la concentration !
C’est vraiment crucial pour écrire efficacement.
Afin d’atteindre une concentration maximum,
Stephen King s’isole de manière radicale,
dans une pièce et un bureau dédiés à l’écriture.
C’est la règle de « la porte fermée ».
Pour se couper encore plus du monde extérieur,
il met du hard rock - surtout AC/DC, Guns
n’ Roses, ou Metallica - à plein volume.
Pas de distraction - pas de téléphone, pas
d’internet non plus, j’imagine - pas d’interruption
intempestive.
Donc, en théorie, personne ne peut le déranger
; mais bon, Stephen King tolère quand même
que sa femme le dérange.
On passe maintenant à des règles d'écriture
plus techniques, ce qu’il appelle la « boite
à outils » de l’écrivain.
La grammaire, c’est synonyme de calvaire
pour beaucoup de gens, mais c’est impossible
de faire sans.
Haristote avec un Bescherelle
Parce que le non-respect de la grammaire se
traduit par de la confusion des incohérences.
Mais bon, Stephen King nous rassure quand
même.
Déjà, on sous-estime notre maîtrise de
la grammaire : on est généralement moins
mauvais qu’on ne le croit.
Et puis on sous-estime aussi notre capacité
à intégrer la grammaire, alors que la conversation
et la lecture suffisent amplement.
Bref, respectez la grammaire, et n’en faites
pas tout un plat.
Règle plus précise, mais tout de même partagée
par pas mal d’écrivains : la voix active
est préférable à la voix passive.
Par exemple, plutôt que d’écrire « La
réunion aura lieu à sept heures.», il faut
écrire « La réunion sera tenue à sept
heures.
»
Pour Stephen King, le recours à la voix passive,
c’est un aveu de faiblesse ; selon lui,
c’est le même manque d’assurance que
celui de l’amant passif, qui n’ose pas
prendre l’initiative.
Bon, je ne suis pas totalement certain de
la valeur de la métaphore ; mais si elle
peut vous aider à vous rappeler d’éviter
la voix passive, eh bien pourquoi pas.
Stephen King déteste les adverbes !
Rarement, également, admirablement, certainement,
complètement, probablement, etc.
Stephen King compare les adverbes aux pissenlits
: un de temps en temps, ça n’est pas trop
grave ; mais si on n’y prête pas attention,
on commence à en mettre partout, et là c’est
comme une pelouse recouverte de pissenlits
- c’est l’horreur !
On peut généralement se passer des adverbes,
parce que le contexte à lui seul suffit.
Alors, après, Stephen King avoue ne pas toujours
respecter lui-même cette règle, parce qu'il
a souvent peur que le lecteur ne le comprenne
pas.
En fait, le problème profond c’est : dans
quelle mesure est-ce que l’auteur peut compter
sur l’intelligence du lecteur ?
Mais bon, la règle simple c’est d’éviter
les adverbes.
On considère généralement que c’est la
phrase qui est l’unité du paragraphe, mais
pour Stephen King, c’est le paragraphe.
La différence entre les livres faciles et
agréables à lire et ceux qui sont plus difficiles
se voit souvent à ce niveau : les premiers
comportent généralement de nombreux paragraphes
courts et beaucoup d’espaces blancs ; les
seconds, en revanche, ont déjà un aspect
rébarbatif et compact, avec des paragraphes
interminables et mal séparés, de manière
incohérente.
Le paragraphe
idéal doit être net et pratique : la première
phrase présente le sujet, et les suivantes
l’expliquent.
C’est donc paradoxalement assez difficile
d’écrire un paragraphe clair et simple
à lire, parce que ça demande à l’écrivain
de filtrer et d’organiser sa pensée.
Pour citer Stephen King : « Un texte est
de la pensée filtrée.
»
Pour autant, il est préférable de ne pas
trop penser aux coupures des paragraphes,
et plutôt de les laisser naître naturellement.
En conclusion, ce que montre ce soin apporté
au paragraphe, c’est qu'il faut écrire
pour le lecteur.
Si Stephen King laisse sa femme le déranger
alors même qu’il suit la règle de la « porte
fermée », c’est parce qu’elle a un rôle
crucial à l’égard de sa créativité littéraire.
C’est bien simple : il écrit pour elle.
Comme ils se sont rencontrés très tôt,
à l’université, elle l’a suivi et soutenu
pendant toute sa carrière ; mais surtout,
comme elle a une certaine culture et un goût
littéraires, elle est sa première lectrice.
Du coup, quand il écrit, il le fait toujours
avec l’intention précise et explicite que
le produit fini lui plaise à elle - il veut
l’émouvoir elle, la faire rire elle, et
il imagine très précisément ses réactions.
Elle est donc devenue une pièce fondamentale
de son processus d’écriture : il l’appelle
sa « Lectrice Idéale » (avec 2 majuscules).
Et chacun doit avoir un Lecteur Idéal : une
personne, réelle ou imaginaire, à laquelle
le texte doit plaire en absolue priorité.
D'après Stephen King, tous les livres d’un
écrivain s’adressent sans exception à
son Lecteur Idéal.
Il conseille même, pour rester motivé, d’imaginer
son Lecteur Idéal en chair et en os dans
la pièce.
Romain déguisé dans le coin de la bibliothèque
Alors, ne vous inquiétez pas : il ne s’agit
pas du tout de faire de la télé-réalité
littéraire, d’étaler toute votre vie privée
dans vos textes.
Quand Stephen King recommande de « dire la
vérité », ça concerne l’inspiration
littéraire, principalement pour la fiction.
Dans les cours de création littéraire, à
l’université, il ne supportait pas la prétention
hippie à tirer l’inspiration du néant
- d’ailleurs il trouvait la poésie et la
prose qui naissaient de ce néant complètement
délirantes.
Ensuite, il a cru pendant un temps que son
inspiration dépendait de l’alcool et des
drogues diverses qu’il prenait régulièrement.
Mais quand il a arrêté, il a compris que
ça n’était pas du tout ça.
Non, l’inspiration naît simplement de la
vie personnelle.
L’écrivain emprunte en grande partie ce
qu’il écrit à la réalité vécue.
Il ne peut avoir que quelques thèmes de prédilection,
nés de sa vie et de ses réflexions.
Stephen King reconnaît qu’il est bien possible
d’imaginer totalement ce qu’on écrit
; mais ça doit rester marginal, sinon le
texte ne sera pas réaliste et n’aura pas
d’impact sur le lecteur.
Non, il faut être attentif à ce qui se passe
autour de soi, aux conversations ; puis le
dire.
C’est ça « dire la vérité ».
La philosophie générale d’écriture de
Stephen King, c’est la simplicité.
Les règles 4, 5, 6 et 8 correspondent évidemment
à cette perspective : éviter la voix passive,
les adverbes, faire des paragraphes clairs
et nets, dire la vérité - tout ça c’est
faire simple.
Mais la recherche de la simplicité se manifeste
tout particulièrement dans le vocabulaire.
Les gens croient souvent qu’un écrivain
a toujours beaucoup de vocabulaire et qu’il
écrit forcément de manière compliqué ; or,
c’est faux.
Si de grands écrivains sont célèbres pour
le raffinement complexe de leur style, Stephen
King montre que d’autres le sont tout autant
pour leur style très direct, très simple
- on pourrait même dire pur.
Donc n’essayez pas d’utiliser des mots
longs ou rares ; restez plutôt spontané
: prenez le premier mot qui vient à l’esprit
s’il est approprié et expressif.
Il n’y a pas besoin de faire un effort conscient
pour améliorer son vocabulaire, ça vient
tout seul avec des lectures et avec le temps.
Et encore une fois, un style simple peut être
efficace.
Stephen King se veut rassurant : le vocabulaire,
c’est comme le pénis.
Comme le disait la pute au matelot intimidé
: "L'important, c'est pas ce que tu as, mon
chou, mais comment tu t'en sers.
La simplicité doit plus globalement émaner
de tout le livre.
Comme tout le monde a quelque chose d’intéressant
à dire, il faut être très sélectif : ne
vraiment garder que le meilleur du texte,
ôter, mot par mot, phrase par phrase, tout
ce qui est inutile - un peu comme pour le
montage d’un film.
Une lettre de refus avait d'ailleurs donné
à Stephen King la formule : « Version 2
= Version 1 - 10% ».
Tout texte peut être resserré, et il sera
forcément meilleur après.
Pas avare de métaphores sexuelles, Stephen
King qualifie le processus de « viagra littéraire
».
Stephen King croit au talent, et il nous prévient
que ce n’est pas la peine d’espérer devenir
un génie comme Proust.
Pour autant, il est bien possible, d’après
lui, de devenir un écrivain compétent, voire
même un bon écrivain - c’est-à-dire de
mériter être publié.
Et ce qui rend ce petit miracle possible,
c’est le travail.
Il faut « se casser le cul », comme il l’écrit
plusieurs fois.
En particulier, il faut beaucoup lire et écrire.
Stephen King conseille au débutant de le
faire 4 à 6 heures par jour.
Vous devez écrire dans un lieu dédié, « porte
fermée » - c’est la règle n°2 - mais
vous pouvez lire partout - dès qu’il y
a de l’attente - et vous pouvez lire par
intermittence - 1h par ci, 15 minutes par
là - tant que vous lisez au total plusieurs
heures par jour.
Stephen King lit 70 à 80 livres par an, et
il aime beaucoup les livres audio.
L’effort de lecture est crucial pour l’écriture,
parce qu’il y a un lien intime entre les
deux.
Pour Stephen King, c’est tout simplement
impossible de bien écrire sans lire beaucoup
!
Mais il faut aussi écrire beaucoup !
Issu de la classe moyenne inférieure de l’Amérique,
ayant été ouvrier et ayant vécu dans une
pauvreté relative avant de connaître le
succès, Stephen King défend donc une éthique
du labeur :
écrire, c’est une tâche comme une autre,
donc il est impossible de bien faire sans
efforts.
Il faut se tenir à l’objectif quotidien,
et « se casser le cul ».
Si on veut synthétiser les 10 règles d'écriture,
elles mettent surtout l’accent sur la simplicité,
le travail, et le souci du lecteur.
À moi, cette recette me semble vraiment bonne,
même si l’expérience de Stephen King comporte
plusieurs biais : il écrit des romans ; d’horreur
et fantastiques ; et puis c'est surtout pour
le marché de masse américain.
Mais bon, si vous en êtes conscient, ce livre
est plein de bons conseils.
Pour lire mon article de blog le concernant,
ou ce livre lui-même, les liens sont dans
la description.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, donnez-lui un
pouce bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour
être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour bien écrire.